hello this is Brian Tracy I wanted to
thank Evan for making this video about
my advice on goal-setting and sharing
these important messages with his
audience hello believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems in the
world I started a mentor me series with
the goal to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending more time with
them
some of their mindset their thoughts
their beliefs their attitudes their way
of looking at the world seeps into us to
help us become the best version of
ourself so today we're going to learn
from Brian Tracy and some of his
goal-setting advice mentor me Brian rule
number five is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always guys as you're
watching if somebody says something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
you
you
in order to be successful you must have
one big goal I give a goal setting
exercise all over the world that is life
changing I go back a year later or two
years later or three years later and I
have thousands of people come up to me
almost like us guru Laura sage and they
say you changed my life you made me rich
and I said it was the goals wasn't it
and I said yes it was the goals how did
you know and what I teach is this is
take a piece of paper make a list of ten
goals that you'd like to achieve in the
next 12 months these are 1 year goals
now sometimes I'll have a one day a one
week one month three months six months
but they're all goals that you want to
accomplish within 12 months then you
look over this list and you say if I
could wave a magic wand and achieve any
one goal on this list within 24 hours
which one goal would have the greatest
positive impact on my life and then you
look at your list of ten and the answer
will jump out at you and that becomes
your major definite purpose this becomes
your major goal then you transfer this
to a clean sheet of paper and you write
a deadline when you want to achieve this
goal you make a list of everything that
you could think of it you could do to
achieve this goal you then organize this
list like a checklist in order of
sequence what do you do first what do
you do second what do you do third and
then you take action on your goal and
then you do something on that goal every
day seven days a week it's a very simple
system decide the most important goal
write it down
make a plan work on it every day and
that all of your other goals will start
to move forward you'll start to make
progress on the big goal but all the
other goals will start to move forward
almost without you even paying attention
to them
so that's really the key to success is
single focus Warren Buffett and Bill
Gates were at a dinner party with Bill
Gates father and a large number of other
people at Bill Gates home in Seattle
last year and they were chatting with
each other they're very good friends and
somebody came up to them and said excuse
me gentlemen I don't mean to interrupt
you but you're three of the most
important most successful people in the
world Bill Gates and Warren Buffett are
number one number two wealthiest man in
the world what would you say is the
was important ingredient for success and
they all stopped broke off their
conversation and all turn simultaneously
and looked at the man and said focus
focus is the most important quality for
success if you can focus you can do
anything if you can't focus you must
always work for someone else who will
make you focus now wonderfully enough
focusing is like learning how to ride a
bicycle or type of the keyboard
it's a learn about skill you can learn
to focus by practicing focus until it
becomes automatic one of my favorite
quotes is from good to the German
philosopher and he said everything is
hard before it's easy so the formation
of any new habit is hard before it's
easy you have to keep working at it it's
just like a bicycle you keep falling
down you have to keep getting back up
again until finally it becomes easier
and easier and soon it becomes automatic
and when you automatically get up each
day plan your day and work on your most
important goal your whole life will
transform so here are some guidelines
for writing your goals first make sure
you write them in the present tense as
if your goal had already been achieved
for example instead of saying I will
earn X amount of dollars each year right
I earn X dollars each year the reason
that we do this is because your
subconscious mind can only register
commands that are phrased in the present
tense next write your goals in the
positive sense so instead of saying I
will quit smoking you would like I am a
nonsmoker finally write your goals in
the personal tense in other words all of
your goals should start with a word I
this is the only way that your
subconscious recognizes that this is a
command coming from the head office is
when you say I is an action verb in the
positive sense I earn X number of
dollars
this year there's a process which has
made more people rich than any other
single process of goals achieving and
it's to take your major goal and
structure it as a question if your goal
is to earn $100,000 a year then you
write how can I earn $100,000 in the
next 12 months
that's an open-ended question not how
can I earn it at my job or doing a
specific thing just an open-ended
question how can I earn the amount of
money and then you discipline yourself
to write 20 answers to the question and
the 20 answers are all the different
things that you could think of to earn
$100,000 work a longer work harder
upgrade my skills just get a new job
would you take a part-time opportunity
whatever it happens to be write down
everything you could think of but force
yourself to write at least 20 questions
or 20 answers to the question the 20
question method called mind storming
forces you to dig deep deep into your
mind where you will find all your
answers and it may be call a person a
read a book let me give you an example
we had a young fellow entrepreneur 35
years old he built his successful
business he'd worked about 10 years to
do it and he for two years wanted to
sell his business so he could take a
year off and travel enjoy his money and
so for two years he just sort of
floundered around like a fish on the
dock wanting to sell his business nobody
offered to buy it he suggested it to
people people were not interested and so
on and in this exercise that they put
him through his twentieth answer and
often it's the 20th answer that is the
breakthrough was buy a book on how to
sell your own business and it just went
off like a flashbulb in his mind had to
break he got up as a downtown hotel got
up went down to the street to a major
bookstore went and found he was amazed
at the number of books had been written
on how to buy and sell a business so he
bought two or three books two months
later he had restructured packages
business sold it completely satisfactory
and took a year off he said it was just
a single idea it was a breakthrough idea
but it was so simple just get a book
the subject and you think boy that's
pretty obvious yes but it's the most
obvious answers that we overlooked one
of the most valuable exercises you can
engage in when setting goals is to ask
yourself what is my limiting step
what is the one factor that determines
the speed at which I achieve my goal or
whether I achieve it at all throughout
my personal development your ability to
identify your limiting step is one of
the best demonstrations of your
intelligence and a step toward building
self-confidence your capacity to
eliminate this limiting step is one of
the best demonstrations of your overall
competence in achieving anything you
want in studying everything that has
been written or said about personal
development and success the conclusion I
came to was that your level of self
confidence is probably the critical
factor in everything you accomplish when
you have enough self-confidence you will
try almost anything because success is
largely a matter of averages or
probabilities the more things you try
the more likely it is that you will
achieve greatly the same is true for you
by setting goals trying more things
engaging in more activities and
exploring more opportunities your
probabilities of success increased
dramatically
the only real limiting step that you
might have is your level of self
confidence when you reach the point at
which you believe in yourself absolutely
the barriers that exist in your external
world will not stop you the major
obstacles to success always lie within
the mind of the individual they are not
contained in external circumstances or
situations or people by building self
confidence you win the inner battle the
outer battle seems to take care of
itself I've learned three important
ideas for building self-confidence
first accept complete responsibility for
yourself and for everything that you are
and ever will be
second accept that you can change your
situation only by going to work on
yourself and learning the things you
need to know in order to be better third
setting goals with timelines for the
things that you want and then working on
them every day to bring those goals into
reality build your self-confidence many
years ago at a talk I was speaking to
Rich DeVos when he was on his way
efforts to boss the president of Amway
were 5.3 billion dollars today started
off knocking on doors selling soap and
he was working his way up and I asked
him I said what have you found what's
the most important quality of successful
people and he said Brian he said we
found there's a direct relationship I
still remember him telling me this
between how quickly a person takes
action on a new idea and how like it is
they'll ever take action on any idea at
all and so the action orientation is the
critical thing we watch people everybody
hears the same things they hear the same
ideas but then we watch and we see how
quickly they take action and if a person
takes action quickly on a new idea the
chances are they're going to be
successful go up by hundreds of percent
now what most people do is they say
that's a great idea so wonderful I get I
love I'm going to do that oh I'm so
excited but before I apply it I need to
take a vacation to a wonderful place
called Sunday I'll and so they go to
some day I'll and they live on some day
I'll and who are they surrounded with on
Sunday I'll other people on Sunday I'll
and what is the chief topic of
conversation on some day I'll yes it's
their excuses what's your excuse for not
taking action what's your excuse for not
getting one what's your excuse for not
losing weight getting out of debt
building your business writing your book
getting your book finished getting your
damn book started you know in other
words what is your what's your Excuse
than all share excuses hell that's a
good exists I haven't used that one for
a long time
that'll Val Val Val gave me another year
and so what they do is they sit around
and the bottom 80% of the population
lives on some day I almost of their
lives they all have these great
resolutions but and these wonderful
intentions but what's their hold to help
pave with it
good intentions and I'm going to do that
somebody else so rule number one for
success is whatever you learn here vote
yourself off the island
no more some day I'll I could do it or
don't do it prepare in advance you know
the old saying
proper prior preparation saves poor
performance or prevents poor performance
the six PS and so prepare your work list
for the following day the evening or the
night before the last thing you do at
the end of the day is you lay out the
day that's coming the best exercise is
for you to plan your entire next day as
the last thing you do before coming home
from work when you plan your day the
night before your subconscious mind then
goes to work on your plans and goals
while you're asleep very often you'll
wake up in the morning with ideas and
insights that apply to the work of the
day now a major benefit of preparing
your daily list the night before is that
this exercise that you sleep more
soundly a major reason for insomnia is
people lying awake trying not to forget
to remember everything that they have to
do the following day but once you've
written down everything that you have to
do on the list it clears your mind and
enables you to sleep deeply this will
help you increase your productivity
throughout the whole next day at work
because you'll be more relaxed and more
refreshed
get yourself a reward of some kind for
practicing the new behavior each time
you reward yourself you reform and
reinforce that behavior soon you begin
to associate at an unconscious level the
pleasure of the reward with the behavior
you set up your own forcefield of
positive consequences that you
unconsciously look forward to as a
result in engaging in that behavior or
habit that you've decided upon so what
do you think holds people back they
think they know what they want to do but
they just can't keep the habit to do it
once and then they follow up the train
and then next you want to do it again
and they follow the Train how do you
make that consistent well you just keep
you just keep working at it and working
it the best way of all this trip planet
in advance
instead of sitting down never start work
without a list and never start work
without prioritizing your list people
sit down and they say well before I make
a list of check a little email check a
little spam ascend something to my
friends see what's going on YouTube and
so on and so forth and then they look up
but it's 10 o'clock and they haven't
done anything of value so what you do is
you have to say you know well well you
know what if what if it whether they say
that if you started right it'll work out
right so start it as week on your most
important task and do that until it
becomes a habit
here's an interesting thing about
checking email is when you check email
it triggers the release of dopamine in
your brain dopamine is a drug but by the
way there's about all kinds of books and
articles and scientific studies on this
and dopamine is the same drug in cocaine
and what it does is it's triggered every
time you have a shiny object or
something new or different or
interesting or sparkling if a telephone
rings next to you you will ping your
brain releases endorphins and you can't
hardly wait to see what it is so you're
talking to somebody and you could be
talking to somebody about something very
serious and your telephone goes off boom
your whole mind goes blank because the
middle of the conversation stops you've
grabbed for your phone you pick it up
you look at it you check it out
everything else and then you come back
if you're working on a task it takes an
average of 17 minutes to get back to the
task and then there's another
distraction so another 17 minutes
average adult is checking their email
between 10 and their phone between 95
145 times a day it's very easy which
means they're like attention deficit
disorder dogs they're just literally
running around back and forth the whole
day at the end of the day they're
exhausted by the way USA Today and and
Harvard approved that you lose one IQ
point for every hour where you that you
leave your email on at the end of the
day you've lost 10 IQ points you
actually become stupor throughout the
day
dumber and here's I ask this of my
audiences I say have you ever finished
today we don't think you've accomplished
anything you get an email responding to
bings and beeps and links and so on all
day at the end of the day you go home
and honey says what do you want for
dinner you said I don't know I don't
care anything I just want to drink
because you're so exhausted you cannot
even decide sit there and basically like
you've just been you know punched in the
side of the head because your brain your
brain is dead and you lose 10 IQ points
you get stupider throughout the day
you've got to turn that darn thing off
if you want to remain sharp develop the
habit you said what you do out the habit
and I'm going to give myself my reward
and my reward will be to check my email
after I finished my first task so all of
success in life is task completion let
me repeat that I just had a long
conversation with an entrepreneur he
almost fell off his chair I was coaching
him and he said he'd never heard that
before and then I spoke to my pitch
group I was telling you in Japan I told
them the same thing and they were just
flabbergasted is the key to success in
life is task completion if you don't
complete tasks you have no future
and so if task completion is the key
then what you do is you complete more
and more important tasks and if you
start every day by completing a at the
most important task your brain actually
releases endorphins now endorphins is
another chemical and it's only released
when you do something that is life
enhancing and what that means is when
you do something that is good for you
that enhances your life that furthers
you it makes you happy
it releases energy it raises your
self-esteem is sort of safe if you if
you want to be a winner how do you be a
winner when you win and winning means
you cross the finish line so if you
start to complete a task you're actually
winning and you get a feeling of being a
winner which gives you a suffusion of
energy and inspiration and it drives you
and motivates you to want to get that
feeling again so how do you get that
feeling again you start I'll beat
another task so I've developed the habit
and people who are successful throughout
the habit of starting and completing
tasks so my wife comes in and says
dinners in five minutes so I look at my
list
I say okay there's a five-minute task
and what are going to start and complete
a five-minute task and each time you
complete a task you get a burst of
endorphin the bigger the task the more
endorphin the more endorphin the more
quickly you become addicted to starting
and completing important tasks and every
single successful person has a
reputation for starting and completing
important tasks you want the job done
give it to him or her you want the
product served on time you'll have the
product completed you want the product
manufacture ship delivered give it to
him give it to her give it to that
company yes they always deliver that's
the best reputation you can have if you
want to get rich hello this is Brian
Tracy I wanted to thank Evan for making
this video about my advice on
goal-setting and sharing these important
messages with these audience I also want
to encourage each of you to use the
advice here to take action on achieving
your goals and pursuing your dreams
instead of living on some day I'll some
day I'll do this
some day I'll do that but you never do
it take action and take action now thank
you guys so much for watching I'd love
to know what did you think of this video
what was your favorite clip and why what
lesson are you going to pull from this
clip and immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business please
leave it down the comments below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shout out to Nathan from
the productivity game channel Nathan
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and making that
awesome youtube video review on it I
really appreciate the support man and
I'm glad you enjoyed the block
Carmichael states that there is one word
that defines who you are
connects all the things in your life
that make you come alive and will help
you escape the chains of mediocrity so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon